the markets did not take the tariff news
well the Dow plunged almost 600 points
before closing off 420 today the S&P 500
was down 36 the Nasdaq lost 92 deirdre
Boldin of the Fox Business Network joins
us from New York to tell us maybe what
all this means good evening Deirdre
good evening Brightwell markets closed
near their session lows after President
Trump said the US would place a 25
percent tariff on imported steel 10%
tariffs on imported aluminum so one
strategist told me if you own a steel
mill great if you don't you are out of
luck so steel and aluminum stocks they
were among the only ones that closed
higher in today's session many see the
president's plan is a strike against
China analysts say China floods the
world's markets with cheap metals but
the trick is that we also buy metals
from allies such as Canada in Japan the
Defense Department has cautioned against
creating a backlash from friendly
trading partners the president's plan
also exceeded by a few percentage points
the most aggressive levels that the
Commerce Department had included in a
study last spring so numerous industry
leaders they voiced concern today
including the head of the motor
Equipment Manufacturers Association
metal tariffs hurt American
manufacturers that use steel and
aluminum which means Americans are going
to pay more for everything from cars to
beer which is sold in aluminum cans
potential trade wars also threaten
American exporters an American firm can
lose access just point-blank to a
foreign market or American goods are
taxed so heavily in retaliation that
lost money and lost jobs follow American
farmers one group with a lot to lose
they sell tons of soybeans to China
American distilleries sell lots of
bourbon in Europe in answering his
critics while President Trump has
implied that the benefits of new trade
limits will outweigh costs the president
has said he would not assign the formal
order until next week and officials are
saying that companies and countries can
petition for exemptions to the new
policies those this may be president
Trump's way of starting negotiations
right back to you see where that goes
dear Joe thank you